[Music]
to live a life of responsibility life
she can never be a part of except by
constantly getting kidnapped and
requiring rescue pizzeria misspells
Bleecker on their helmet decals did the
customer tell you he was gonna go to
pizza yard if you didn't deliver these
pizzas on time because that's odd that
in all New York City worried about only
one pizza place taking your business
Peter actually wastes most of his time
trying to deliver the pizzas on his
moped instead of using superpowers Pizza
Sheriff asshole who can't work a bungee
cord instead prise open one box and
somehow slides out one piece of pizza
without all the cheese and bits sliding
off okay so Peter comes out of the
janitor closet because he had to change
out of his spider-man outfit but how did
this receptionist miss spider-man with a
bunch of pizzas walking into the janitor
closet in the first place
mysterious ceiling panel or is he Batman
Peter tries to sell a Photoshop pictures
a real photo
Peter apparently attends assface
University so how are things going at
Oscorp oh they're great I'm head of
Special Projects what how many 15 years
have passed since the last movie Aunt
May later says it's - that's nowhere
near long enough for Harry as portrayed
in these movies to ever be anything at
Oscorp other than ahead of half-assing
or manager of macking on chicks or about
to make the breaks on fusion fusion
fusion fusion fusion man Hollywood
really knows how to jump on the
bandwagon and ride it for decades don't
they are actually funding one of your
idols Pete Otto Octavius I'm writing a
paper on him I know what a crazy
coincidence hey you're still here yeah I
mean this is the house where you got
verbally abused in why the fuck would
you stick around after the party to hang
there intelligence it's not a privilege
it's a gift and you use it for the good
of mankind you might even say that with
great intelligence comes great I'll
forget did beethoven's sleep before he
wrote the fifth did Bernoulli sleep
before he found the curves of quickest
descent brown-nosing he was studying
science and I was studying English
literature I was trying to explain the
theory of relativity wow that must have
been one hell of an opening line to talk
to a girl hello my name is Otto Octavius
measurements of various quantities are
relative to the velocities of observers
I'm going to a symposium on quantum
mechanics later you should come if you
want to get a woman to fall in love with
you feed her poetry never fails it fails
is he doing he already turned down Mary
Jane because he's spider-man and could
still have her if he wanted but now he's
brushing up on poetry because also Peter
reads poetry aloud at a laundromat
Peter spidey senses blissfully unaware
of danger 30 feet behind him there were
a lot of cop cars behind Peter when he
made this leap but all the traffic in
this Lane is gone when he lands so that
he could have a cute moment with these
kids he inspires one with absolute
credulity discount actress wrestler
announcer guy from the first movie
decided to pursue his dream of being a
theater usher in the second Peter was
only talking for one minute but the
payphone requests more money anyway
Otto skips over his finger oculus
cerebellum attached smart bionic arm
invention to get to what ultimately is
his failed fusion reactor experiment I
developed this inhibitor chip to protect
my higher brain functions another
miraculous invention glossed over like
it's nothing what other world-changing
inventions is auto-create
and tossed aside in his path diffusion
now wearing the inhibitor chip gives a
person cancer so I had to cure that
before I could proceed with my research
brilliant thoughtful scientist thinks
that this is just a spike couldn't
Spidey have slung a bunch of webs and
unplug the fusion reactor for why didn't
he just kind of walk over and unplug
them rather than jumping to the ceiling
and announcing it with great power comes
great shards of glass that will kill
your wife Otto's wife looks good for
someone who got glassed in the face we
interrupt the spider-man movie to bring
you revenge of the sith this bank offers
a free toaster for opening an account
with $300 in it what is this the 50s
Peter just happens to be at the bank
when Doc Ock decides to rob it
man in sunglasses hat and long dark
trench coat Stan's staring at the bank
vault for way longer than any bank would
allow without some kind of security
checking it also do banks just have
their huge safe and public view aren't
those usually tucked in the back
somewhere spidey sense its kind of gone
didn't it
oh that boy yours is a real hero irony
what the hell kind of bank keeps gold
coins loose in bags in their vault
those things are chocolates Peter's
powers go out during the bank fight
enough to further his own self doubt but
return just in time to keep him from
actually getting killed because of their
absence random victim is not random of
course because this can't be a ruse at
all man it's a good thing she brought
this umbrella even though it's the
sunniest day ever and that she
remembered it when she fled the bank and
that she never dropped it during doc
Ock's kidnapping
Aunt May is grabbed by Doctor Octopus
but we never hear him climb up to her
level which is impossible when he has
four metal claws grabbing into brick to
climb the building all right men
that old lady in the vigilante are out
of the way open fire on that bad guy in
the apartment building full of people
behind him showed him you sound exactly
like my nephew it would explain a lot
yeah but Mary Jane just happens to be
dating Jay jonah Jameson's son who cares
so much about me whoa whoa well there
may be their best friends in the comics
are some but in these movies they
haven't come close to establishing any
kind of best friend relationship and I
just want you all to know that the
beautiful Miss Mary Jane Watson just
agreed to marry me this is what we call
an orgy of evidence that Peters life
sucks ass right now I mean this is a
nasty spill and if the webs aren't
working wouldn't the super-strength also
be failing even with super-strength can
you survive a fall like this later he
tries to climb the wall and falls and
his vision starts sucking but strength
all good Peter took this newspaper from
the dumpster all the way home just so
Sam Raimi could have this cool little
transition job these blurry extras are
all smiling and watching Tobey Maguire
do this silly walk take real New Yorkers
did not stop and stare at silly walkers
[Music]
easy freeze-frame mary-jane didn't even
hail this cap the driver doesn't even
look like he knows she's about to get in
50 bucks I could get more than that on
eBay
alright a hundred this guy accepts a
measly $100 for the Spidey costume
because Jonah and the movie just uh sure
amount without an argument 1977 New York
City attacks a guy in broad daylight
with thousands of people walking by well
there used to be thousands of people
walking by but they cleared out so Peter
could reflect on his goals and ideals
Harry's obsession with finding
spider-man never included following
Peter around or having him followed also
Harry thinks he can find spider-man by
tracking him via a newspaper article
your father owned obsessed over his work
discount Alfred Pennyworth
kill spider-man I'll give you all the
tricky meanings or you could just
torture Harry now and get it that way oh
no spider-man one got spliced into this
movie someone's child is in the burning
building cliche this doorknob would be
scalding hot in a burning building the
no powered Peter Parker holds onto a
ledge while carrying a kid and this
movie suspension of disbelief
[Music]
are you fucking kidding me some poor
soul got trapped on the fourth floor
oh no if only Peter still had the powers
of spider-man he could totally have not
saved that guy anyway where are all my
comic books
oh those dreadful things I gave those
away Aunt May is a Philistine Henry and
I agree we don't see his picture in the
paper anymore was there chance you might
disagree about that it's like Henry need
a hero courageous self-sacrificing
people diabetics having a sugar low have
been known to pop the scene of the movie
in to help give their glucose levels of
boost surely there's a safer way for
Peter to figure out if he could be
spider-man again like that time in the
first one where he was just trying to
climb a wall or spin a web I guess Peter
never needed Spidey powers to survive
Falls like this back on the moon Wow
lucky for Peter and MJ that his powers
just happened to start working again one
second before they were both crushed by
a car
also Doc Ock throws a motherfucking car
at the one guy he needs to get his
precious tritium how did dr. octopus
know that Peter would be here so Doc Ock
through a car from some hidden place
around where these people are running
with perfect accuracy into a coffee shop
that he should have had no idea Peter
was actually in that should definitely
have killed him Mary Jane is in some
kind of danger cliche
even though Peters mine believed that he
was no longer spider-man the power of
boners is stronger well I won't be
needing these ever again for any reason
forever and ever
hey guys quick question where is this
Webb attaching itself when spider-man
swings over to this clock tower ah the
downtown Manhattan elevated train they
shot this movie half a century ago you
know or in Chicago Doc Ock throws one
person at a time so that Spidey has a
chance to see Doc Ock considers the
throwing people off the train idea a
failure when he could have just upped
the ante by throwing more people he's
got four claws he could throw four
people and at the same time rather than
that one by one bolt during a
life-or-death situation this guy decides
to be a dick to the one guy who can save
everyone on the train
and there's one great shot of paper
football Jesus symmetry oh wow the mass
that he tore off while riding on top of
the subway 30 blocks ago good fine bull
New Yorkers band together in a crisis
cliche and the tritium oh that we keep
that in a safe here in the penthouse
bedroom slash science storage facility
wait a second earlier he was unconscious
and then woke up and was so weak that
Doc Ock didn't have any trouble taking
him prisoner now he wakes up from a
second coma and suddenly he's fully
rested and strong like comas are like
refilling your health bar or something
[Music]
there are bigger things happening here
just say your father tried to kill me
with the blades on his glider and I
dodged it and it hit him instead that's
not a very long sentence Mary Jane is in
some kind of danger cliche the small
effusion is pulling the building apart
and even pulling random taxicabs and
other cars over in the city but then
Spiderman and alq take like five minutes
to get around to stopping it and somehow
the world hasn't evaporated yet robotic
smart arms have the same weakness as the
aliens and signs sometimes to do what's
right we have to be steady and give up
the thing they want the most even our
dreams and with great power comes great
responsibility
it means Luca Brasi sleeps with the
fishes rosebud here's looking at you kid
that escalated quickly Coffee is for
closers only there were some sort of
powers I had that I could use to sling
you to safety
drown it oh well the self-sustaining
ball of fusion power also has the same
weakness as the aliens from science
Mary Jane isn't some kind of danger
cliche I guess Aunt May was wrong in the
first movie spider-man is Superman
[Music]
unless I get depressed or have an
identity crisis or whatever it was that
caused me to lose my powers in this
movie I'm a new Harry look in the first
movie Norman became insane after he
tried to inject himself with that serum
but Harry becomes insane because
spider-man 3 has to happen
conveniently are smashing leaves Harry
to the Green Goblin lair complete with
everything he needs where is your
f---ing spider sense right now you
fucking idiot
[Music]
Keep Calm it's alia spiked ever since
cinemasins began the most requested
thing has been TV since and now it's a
reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes oh you're in
charge well I got some bad news for you
[Music]
you
samandar he needs help not change the
subject Bob we're discussing your he is
getting mugged my only love sprung from
my only hate this is really heavy
there's that word again
heavy wireframes are having their
futures are a problem with the Earth's
gravitational pull
honey are you sure you know sell thank
you okay so that's up there
[Music]
ah
this is my dream y'all all this look
mush
I got gold bullets look at my they say
nothing I got I got rooms of this I got
my dark tanning oil lay out by the pool
but on my dark tanning oil
my spaceship USS Enterprise on this I'll
go to different planets on this man
me and my Franklin's here we take off